y llegaron los primeros envíos de ayuda
médica estadounidense a india el viernes
este avión militar descargó más de 400
botellas de oxígeno así como otros
equipos hospitalarios en nueva delhi
mientras el país se enfrenta a una
crisis sanitaria sin precedentes en
muchas regiones los hospitales se están
quedando sin camas oxígeno y
medicamentos buscaban incluso la máscara
de oxígeno y las mangueras que se
conectan a la bombona son muy difíciles
de encontrar
me pasé días para encontrarlas también
hay escasez de médicos no pudimos
encontrar un médico para tratar a mi
padre todos los médicos locales son
positivos al coronavirus entonces vemos
vídeos en youtube sobre cómo administrar
el oxígeno china también se une a la
cooperación internacional para india el
viernes
beijing cuyas relaciones con nueva delhi
son tensas declaró que envió más de
26.000 respiradores y casi 3.800
toneladas de material médico y
medicamentos
en los próximos días se seguirán
enviando más recursos contra la pandemia
en india para apoyar los esfuerzos anti
de este país
en más de 40 países se han comprometido
a enviar ayuda médica para salvar vidas
emilia en total las promesas de ayuda
incluyen casi 550 instalaciones de
producción de oxígeno 17 camiones
cisterna criogénicos y miles de dosis de
vacunas y es que a pesar de ser el mayor
productor de vacunas del mundo
inia no tiene suficientes reservas para
hacer frente a la segunda ola de
infecciones en medio de esta crisis
mumbai anunció el viernes que se veía
obligado a cerrar sus centros de
vacunación durante tres días por falta
de dosis